foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
Belfast Telegraph Economist Alison
Morris and the chief executive of the
charity business in the community Mary
McLeod they'll both be with us from now
right up until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now well the times reports
on the chancellor Jeremy Hunt's major
fiscal policy speech in which he
emphasized what he feels is the need to
prioritize tax cuts for businesses over
those for individuals
the express also leads on that speech
and says Mr Hunt's policies will help
get millions of people back to work
while the male says ministers are
looking at ways of reforming pensions to
encourage people over the age of 50 to
get back into the workplace
the mirror says the world's five biggest
oil companies are poised to announce
profits of 160 billion pounds
the financial times has news of an
admission from hm revenue and Customs
but it gave incorrect information last
summer when it said no government
ministers were under investigation of
course it turned out Nadeem zahawi was
though he denies any wrongdoing
the guardian leads with an investigation
into foreign governments famous names
and a billionaire business figures
buying large amounts of land and
property in the UK using offshore
Arrangements
and the eye carries the result of a
survey which suggests that while many
people are unhappy with what they regard
as the effects of brexit there was no
clear majority on the question of
rejoining the EU
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Alison
Morris and Mary McLeod welcome to both
of you good evening let's start with the
express and this story the chancellor um
really dangling perks under people's
noses to get them back to work to get
the over 50s back to work he says that
your country needs you Alison
I don't know any over 50s who are not
working at this point I'd love to know
who these are these over 50s are you're
all relaxing and kicking back at home
um at this point in time and it also
says he's gonna you know when it's tax
perks for people over 50 to encourage
pensioners and the long-term sick to get
back into the workforce I'm not sure
that this is the answer to Kickstart the
economy because the problem is with jobs
at the other end so I mean in lots of
Industries such as teaching I have
friends who were in teaching years
before they could get a full-time job
because retired teachers were
continually coming back in and taking up
those jobs where they were refusing to
retire at a certain age and they were
staying in and sort of job blocking
almost those jobs you imagine to get the
economy running to we need to open up
jobs at the other end and also if you
look at the industries that are having
problems in terms of construction all of
those things that slowed down during the
lockdown and you're not going to get too
many 65 year olds you know carrying
Hudson on building sites I mean they're
young people's jobs and jobs that need
to be created for young people so I mean
while I think it's good to encourage
people who can't work to go out to work
and I'm assuming that if you're over 50
and you're not working you've you've
some sort of pension that I'm certainly
not
um and true enough because I think I'd
still be sitting here hopefully not
speaking to ourselves at one of seven
day trying to make 11 because my pension
is super
um but you know the the real problem
with the economy is getting young people
and those people who are desperate
graduates and people here at the other
end does that scale back out to work
rather than trying to encourage people
who have already retired back into the
workforce Mary do you think Allison's
right in that perhaps the chancellor is
looking to to tap it an incorrect source
for for a new Workforce
oils get nervous when you talk about
older people in their 50s
um I think that's definitely something
about the 50s age group and if you look
at doctors their pension needs to be
sorted so that we can keep doctors
um working as long as possible and that
is something that structurally needs to
change within their their pensions I
think there's definitely people being
encouraged back into work and that may
be things but dealing with of course
skills and and also menopause and other
things that you that the workplace needs
to take account of but in the end I mean
I think it's
um you know the point about this which
sectors you know it's whether it's
schools where there's hospitals
Hospitality Care Homes it's across all
sectors that there's Challenge on skills
and talents so so I guess what Jeremy
Hunt was was doing was setting out a
vision his vision for long-term
prosperity in the UK trying to get is
about I think three million back into to
work
um and a and and there's also about sort
of productivity so there is a huge
economic potential around around the UK
but it's going to take some time and I
think it's it's great to hear the
optimism and they should definitely sort
of try it but it's not just the one
thing that will solve everything yes we
read that 6.6 million uh economically
inactive the chance of saying we will
look at the conditions necessary to make
work worth your while um Allison do you
think that there are any conditions that
will get people back I mean you're
saying it might not be that many of the
over 50s but but get people back into
the workforce who've chosen not to work
at this point in time
yeah like where I read the headline and
it said to encourage pensioners back to
work and then it said tax breaks for
over 50s and I'm like I'm over 50. I'm
not a pensioner and my head I'm like 25
so why am I the adopted logged in with
pensioners and then um in this class but
yeah I mean I do think that you know
um some people may have retired and then
regretted return and just feel really
bored and want to go back out to work
and they have skills obviously that
they'll be of use but I mean that's not
going to be a great deal of people and
anybody else who's over that age and
managed to retire and the shiban is
financially well off enough that they
don't need to work
um and the job creations and to try and
get the economy boosting is there's just
so many sectors that are lacking in
staff and obviously all the staff that
was lost specifically to hospitality
because of brexit and the fact that you
know immigration rules changed um all of
that it's trying to look at her then you
fill those holes and we notice that
we're all saying that um during the
covert pandemic the shortage of nurses
and doctors and those sort of really
skills now and the only way you can do
that is investors in universities and
making sure that they're coming through
and being trained but
um you know it's it's a nice idea if he
thinks it's going to get but I'm not
sure how many people it's going to
encourage back back out to work again we
shall see let's move to the times and
then they're concentrating on the
Chancellor's part of the speech
addressing tax cuts in which he's saying
that tax cuts for businesses will be
prioritized over those for uh workers
and that's his solution or at least
that's the the way that he's going to um
uh order tax cuts it will be businesses
first Mary
yes and I think that is definitely part
of the the solution so he's wanting to
try and first control inflation reduce
inflation and then reduce taxation on
businesses and I remember lobbying
government for getting rid of business
rates and he was mentioning that because
I do think it's an unfair attacks and
employers National Insurance as well
um he talked about so there are
definitely things that that they can do
but employers are having to be much more
flexible now and really look at the
needs of Staffing and employees because
they're given the the war for talent
it's so important that they focus on
what
um is right for so that they can do to
retain that talent and and that includes
you know doing a huge bank for
supporting employees through this really
difficult time because this is a cost of
living crisis that we're in and so
people want to see delivery on these
things by government but businesses are
also trying to do something we've just
launched a cost of living task force
with businesses to say look there are
things that you can do to support your
employees your customers your suppliers
and also local communities and so
whether that is sort of paying the
living wage allowing flexible working
targeting special additional support
where needed for some staff and you know
customers making sure that they're you
know providing affordable products and
services paying promptly suppliers and
promoting volunteering in in communities
so there's a lot of things that can be
done and and businesses can respond some
way to that and we saw it certainly
during the pandemic with the national
business response Network where you know
an example of that in 500
000 people were supported
um and if you take an example Tesco
Mobile
um it gave 1800 telephones to 34
Charities that they could all stay
connected so businesses are trying to do
something to actually support anything
else that's happening that government
may be doing and Allison how do you
think the public will will view that uh
decision to give that the tax cuts to
business over that for individuals
it's I suppose really important in terms
of I'm Dylan I would say I live in
Northern Ireland and we don't have those
huge big Industries and the way other
regions where it's really We're a nation
of of small businesses and they really
do need that sort of relief maybe a
little cooperation tax and all sorts of
other issues to try and keep them afloat
because most were really struggling and
it's the the price of fuel and
everything else that has increased their
costs I mean I work in the newspaper
industry and the cost of printing a
newspaper is almost doubled I mean all
of those things that the cost of that
has to be felt somewhere so I think that
that could be really welcome especially
with those small to medium-sized
businesses who are really struggling
because they don't have that sort of
huge backlog you know of money sitting
at the side they're struggling and
making an end to do from sort of months
to months and so yeah I think that that
would be welcomed if it's able to
trickle down quite quickly and Target
those businesses that need it most
meanwhile we read in the mirror that all
Giants are preparing to announce profits
of 160 billion pounder and this is we
know as far family struggle with their
their energy bills Mary
yes and these headlines aren't good
because people see the struggles that
they have personally with the cost of
living
um and what seems to be sort of huge
profits and that's why you know we've
continued working with businesses to
support as many people as possible and I
think this is you know I also think the
power and the the real influence can
come from bringing together the business
Community government and Civil Society
in our local communities because that
reality of life as it is at the moment
for so many who are living on the
breadline who are going into debt who
don't know where their next meal is
coming from it's an incredibly worrying
time
um and that's where you know we we will
we'll help businesses with creating
those action plans to support all their
employees and and but government has to
do their their piece too to make sure
they're working with the oil companies
and energy companies to give the best
deal possible to customers but Alison
people will be asking that that some of
these profits should be plowed back into
the the customers to help them with
their their bills
seeing when you look at the the scale of
the profits that they've made at a time
when the cost of energy especially just
before Christmas it was soaring to the
point you know where we had you know
pensioners who were sitting in shopping
centers or in coffee shops all day long
just to try and keep warm because they
couldn't afford to turn their heating on
at home you know I I know working you
know mothers who were not turning their
hating on why their children were at
school and trying to save the hate from
When the Children got home and then you
look at things like this and also
businesses who've had their lights put
out by this because they just couldn't
afford to pay the gas bills because
their bills were tripling in some cases
quadrupling and then you see these huge
profits that that these companies are
making and I do think that there's
notice on government to make sure that
these companies are not praying off
people's misery I mean obviously you
know everyone is like to make a profit
that's the whole point of being in
business but when you're making such
obscene amounts of money when people are
struggling you can see why many people
would be angered looking at that front
page tomorrow morning so what do you
believe the government should be doing
in terms of that I do think that they
should be putting a cap on the amount of
profits and that those companies are
allowed to put on the amount of profit
that they're allowed to put on that
energy I mean this should have been
Captain I know that there was talk
before Christmas if there would be
capped Energy prices
um and that should I think should be as
a matter of legislation I don't think
that they should be allowed to just pull
a figure out of their head and that's
with the recharge and we were told this
was a global problem because of the war
in Ukraine but clearly it wasn't a
problem it was a fact of those companies
they were still making their profit
whereas we were having to pay at the
other end of it so if it was an issue
with the war in Ukraine and a shortage
of of Supply well then you imagine their
profit should have been down but instead
they're not they're soaring Mary let's
move to the financial times and Nadeem
zahar we still making the front pages
but but this time it's the UK tax
Authority that have admitted that they
gave misleading information
um last summer when they said that no
government ministers were being
investigated and even though nadeem's a
hobby was very
yes it's a very strange story because
it's you you expect HRC to to know the
detail of what they're they're doing and
so it's frustrating for all of those
people who are finishing tax returns
this weekend and you know it's
frustrating if the hmrc don't get things
right and it shouldn't be difficult for
them to Simply work out if there's any
ministers or politicians who are being
um investigated for this and but it will
hopefully this story will end eventually
and when of course the the the
investigator well the investigation is
going on it was given 10 days so it's
hopefully a quick as ethics advisor
looks into it and Sir Laurie Magnus and
so hopefully we'll get a solution to it
I'm a portion of demons denies any
wrongdoing and he says it's a cure is
not a deliberate tax error but um but it
needs Swift action and and hopefully
we'll get it resolved and because we do
need to rebuild trust in politics and
democracy in our politicians and and
these headlines don't help and because
many do feel it is broken and have lost
trust and and you know and I just feel
it's really important
um that we do and because you know we do
need that trust in the political system
and in democracy so that we can have a
really strong society and so these
stories don't help Alison do you think
this uh um apology now from hm revenue
and Customs that they made a mistake
does this change the story in any way as
you see it
well I I did sort of raise a smile when
I say that the excuse they gave was that
it was mistake and answered I'm a
freedom of information request because
there's a journalist and anyone who's
ever dealt with that sort of foi process
you've almost got to know the answer to
the question before you ask it but I
mean the amount of excuses I've got from
government departments over the years in
terms of foi requests so it's it's
ironic that that's what they're falling
back on as the excuse for this and it
doesn't do so are we any good because
it's drip feeding this information would
actually be better for him had this all
come out in one go but the fact now that
we have this story drifting in various
amounts means it lasts longer it stares
in the headlines longer and raise rate
for public confidence and confidence in
the government confident public
Confluence is an all-time low after the
complete you know shambles of of
leadership um elections last year and
everything else that went on within the
conservative party they really need to
try and get that public confidence back
and so issues like this need to be
resolved and also the Prime Minister
needs to show that he's able to control
his party and to take action against
issues like this in swiftly and make
sure they are often was all very
publicly I do think that there's there's
nothing to be done from Hayden aspects
of this from the public you know you
know what they say you know it's it's
trying to sort of cover it up or just
read things out that's what always ends
up getting people in the end you're
better just being open and honest and
putting the information out there and
let the public see for themselves
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Allison Morris and
Mary McLeod let's have a look at the
Telegraph and this is um obviously gone
to to print before we've had the update
uh they're saying at least five Israelis
are shot dead and several others wounded
this is in the attack
um on the synagogue it's now seven sadly
that number has been revised upwards
um take us into this story Alison
yeah I mean it's really concerned and
that they have their subsurge again of
of violence in the Middle East and we
know that this comes periodically there
was an Israeli attack on the West Bank
this and it was the most deadly in in
decades were I believe it's it's
December's name people killed I know
this terrible attack on a synagogue as
well in Jerusalem this evening and as
news comes through those numbers are
going up at this point in time I think
it's seven plus the the attacker himself
who have been shot dead but I mean the
the escalation of tensions in that
region has always really destabilized in
any way but the fact that this has been
going on I mean from as long as I can
remember we have these subsurges of
valence in this region and the fact that
the response
um I think has always been from the
global Society has nothing good enough
when you look at her you know America
and Britain were able to step up and
step in and help Ukraine and yet we have
this situation you know with um the
Palestinian people in the West Bank and
the terrible conditions that people are
living in Gaza and then also the sort of
the the counter attacks that are
happening in Israel I mean this is
something that I don't think that there
has been enough Global attention but
towards the trying to resolve this long
term for the people in that region you
know I've visited that area myself many
many you know several years ago and such
a beautiful part of the world but just
so troubled and being someone that comes
from a very troubled part of the world
myself but as nine and post-conflict I
really feel for the people who are
living in that region and these
continual cycle surveillance um that are
affected you know elderly children you
know people from all walks of life
yes and our um correspondent out there
in Jerusalem reporting tonight Alistair
bunkel had spoken to to people who are
warning that this could be the start of
another interfada Mary
yes and it's you know it is really sad
and and I'm not similar in that I've
I've always remember this from from such
a long time ago just continued violence
and disturbance in the Middle East and
and it just seems you know so sad that
there's no resolution to it
um at any time and I think it's uh
though many have tried uh but it's just
um you know there's people who are ready
to die to defend their land and and
their lives will all be lost and I think
it's especially sad
um today also course with national
Holocaust Memorial Day
um you know where you know I remember
taking some local school children in
West London
um to see our switch and you know it's
just it's it was just absolutely you
know traumatic to and unrightly that we
sort of commemorate the victims of the
the Holocaust and given that you know
six million Jews were killed at at that
time and and yes so it's really
important that that we still remember
that and try and find a solution to the
the issues in the Middle East